Speaker 1: OK, I have a few sort of like
short Trump stories to go over with you guys,
these these are mostly comedic elements, but
they're also just sad and pathetic and more
about just the sad, sad state of Trumpism
and Republicans in the United States,
which, by the way, they could be in a sad state
and still win in 2022. And in fact, I think it's
quite plausible. So first and foremost, you
guys know about Donald Trump. I'm guessing
you also know about this guy, Mike Lindell. We
know him as Mike Pillow. He's the CEO of MyPillow,
and Mike Lindell has been one of the
main conspiracy to illusionists. Delusion
ists or delusional lists, I guess, is the question
who has been basically since the November 2020
election, saying in December, this thing will be
overturned by January 6th. It will be overturned
by January 20th. It will be overturned. It'll
be March. Trump will be back in office, April
it will be by the summer, it'll be by the end
of summer. The latest, I think, is that it'll
be by Thanksgiving. But clearly that is not going
to happen. And maybe he's forgotten about that.
This is so weird and bizarre. Apparently,
Mike Pillow has recorded what they are
describing as an exclusive blockbuster
interview with Donald Trump and
Trump's wearing a tuxedo in the interview. I don't
know why. I'm guessing there's some explanation.
Maybe this was done. It had an event. Who who
really knows and pillow is promoting? Lindell
is promoting this interview as so earth shattering
that when he plays it the week of Thanksgiving,
the American people are just going to
rise up and demand that Donald Trump
reinstating will be reinstated. And I'm going to
look at just a preview of this interview. It's
completely off the rails. Take a look at this.
Speaker 4: Go back to November 4th and we all
lived in this twilight zone. Why? I always
say like, I was an old saying, you know,
if a tree falls in the forest and no one heard it
didn't really fall well, then the media tells us
there is no forest. I mean, that's where
Speaker 1: I love Trump saying, yeah, as
as if he understands what Pillow is
talking about here, let's continue.
Speaker 4: Back in November and December and
and now, you know, we know, but we were all
living in this twilight zone. You were living
there with us and. But then you had all the
betrayals and attacks on you that escalated to a
whole nother level. And Eric told me, once that
you said right before you were going down that
escalator to make your famous announcement. Can
you imagine that you said? Well, we're going to
find out now who our true friends. It's true.
And and I never forgot that he said that to
me. And you know, it was everyone out there
since that time, we've all been praying for you,
for you to have strength. And my question is,
what does give you the emotional strength?
Speaker 1: It's really a hard hitting blockbuster
interview, as you can imagine. So it's sort of
unclear what Trump is even really doing right now.
He may be, you know, there's this idea that he's
preparing for some kind of big 2022 participation
of sorts in the midterms. He's off Twitter. We
don't really know what it is that he's doing other
than publishing these bizarre statements. So just
to give you an idea of what he's been up to. An
example statement Trump published to his website,
the UN Select Committee of Politically Ambitious
Hacks, continues to subpoena people wanting
to know about those protesting on January 6th,
the insurrection, which took place during
the presidential election of November 3rd.
So Trump is now saying the insurrection
was the election that he claims was stolen.
There is so much proof, but the fake news media
refuses to print it or show it in any way.
Read the Arizona report. Look at Wisconsin,
Pennsylvania, Georgia, numerous other states.
Nothing's happening there. Nothing's happening
in those in those states. So Trump with still
insisting on this stuff and at this point, is
it even to raise money? I don't know Trump. I
was going to say tweeting, but posting blog posts
where he says, look at what they found in Georgia,
74 counties in Georgia are missing ballot images.
OK. Trump posting, I keep wanting to say tweeting
an article from the daily signal claiming
that 26000 dead people are still registered
to vote in Michigan now, remember guys, we've
talked about this dead people voting thing.
Just because someone's registered and died since
being registered doesn't mean they voted in
Michigan, the dead people voting thing has been
widely widely debunked. And then Trump attacking
Liz Cheney with an approval rating at 19 percent
in Wyoming, people are wise to Liz Cheney. She is
a threat to free and fair elections, which are the
cornerstone of our country because she caved so
easily on the crime of the century, meaning the
fact that Joe Biden actually won the election.
This is sad, but I think we
shouldn't underestimate the reality
that there is still energy behind this guy.
And last week's election results, combined with
whatever it is that Trump may have planned for
the midterms, could very well lead. To Republicans
cleaning up in 2020 to taking the House, taking
the Senate, winning more state governorships and
having almost Democrats would have the White House
but having almost total control of the country
for at least a period of a couple of years during
which they could do a ton, a ton a ton of damage.